Welcome to talk to Google.
I'm Kevin Belk and I'm Dana Han Klein.
And today we're welcoming the cast of Warner Bros,
new movie entourage.
So you know them as Ari Vincent Chase,
Eric Murphy and turtle.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome to Google Jeremy Piven,
Kevin Connolly
and director,
creator,
writer,
producer,
Doug Allen.
Yeah,
take a seat.
We'll go down bro.
Hi
Audi.
I liked them.
Alrighty.
So welcome to go guys.
Uh,
such a great job in the movie.
So let's give a round of applause for that
great film.
You know,
Doug,
you did such a great job of giving each character kind of their own sub plot
that fed in Vince is,
and it was just,
it was really,
really good.
And you know,
catching the audience audience up to exactly where they need it to be if they
hadn't seen the series,
but they did kind of getting them up to date with their characters.
So can I want to go through the all you guys and talk about how the evolution of
your characters over the series right into the movie.
And you know,
turtle,
I kind of want to start with you,
Jerry.
Uh,
you know,
you're always probably the slowest character to kind of evolved throughout the
series.
Um,
but then,
you know,
oh,
turtle is a terrorist.
I sat in the back row so you didn't call on me first.
That was my plan and you just blew me up.
So continue,
I got notes from the studio wants it.
Otherwise,
uh,
no,
but you,
the biggest growth throughout the series,
especially once it
hit,
you know,
season six about and you're,
kind of world exploded with,
you know,
meeting up with Mark Cuban.
So can you talk about the evolution of your characters?
Yeah,
yeah.
I,
you know,
I think,
uh,
I also think he maybe had the most room to grow.
If you look at turtle in season one,
he was a negotiating with a girl to make out with him and they'll show her with
Vince eats breakfast in the morning too,
you know,
chasing after Ronda Rousey in,
in the movie.
And also he was making $200 a week is as the driver and then sold the Tequila
company with Mark Cuban and made millions of dollars.
It's one of my favorite lines.
Kevin Dillon is Johnny drama,
shockingly says turtles a millionaire.
And uh,
it's kind of plays itself out in the movie where he gets caught in this romantic
or business angle with,
with Rhonda.
And Doug's done an amazing job.
Evolution.
Ising that's not a word I know.
Turtle.
We've got smart people,
great crowd by the way.
Great.
I know I can't slip.
I can't slip where it's,
I make up by you guys.
That's not fair.
They do it.
How about that?
Jerry's disrupting the vocabulary,
isn't he?
Uh,
well,
you know,
one,
one thing that Vince is supposed to do is be a solid,
steadfast leader for the rest of the guys.
He's,
the example is the rock.
And,
um,
and,
and he is sort of this,
you know,
this,
this is grounding this.
He's,
he's the grounded part that
all of the other guys swirl around.
So,
you know,
I,
I've always really enjoyed bringing that aspect of the character,
the Zen,
like quality,
this nonchalance and you know,
really his evolution is in his career.
And of course in the movie now he not only wants to act but also to direct and
that seems like,
uh,
you know,
the,
the last thing an agent wants to hear their client declare,
um,
but really sets the whole movie in emotion.
Beautiful Segue and a jet.
Mr Jeremy Piven over here with Ari gold.
Yeah.
All right,
good.
These are my people,
man.
This is my demographic right here.
I love it.
As for stock as response.
Exactly.
Um,
if you guys only knew what a caveman I was,
I mean,
I'm on a keypad.
I'm just a disaster,
so it's pathetic.
Um,
Ari had basically one seen the pilot a really great season,
a great moment with Kevin Conley.
Was He at Coi?
And um,
he was a seemingly a complete and utter pig that was cheating on his wife with a
sports illustrated model.
But the reality was,
Doug,
did you always,
was that a mistake or did you,
did you know that he was going to be,
what happened with that?
I never thought we'd go past the pilot,
so I just,
I just wrote the following slide I could come up with and then I'm like,
wow,
if this guy's this better guy,
it's not going to be great.
And,
and uh,
obviously we cast a Perry Reeves is Mrs Ari and she crushed it.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Um,
and Ari is,
is,
is one of these guys who,
um,
you know,
we'll do,
it's by any means necessary to get the job done.
He is a rageaholic and very reactive and a is an equal opportunity offender and
says the unsayable.
And I think that's one of the reasons why people love him.
By the end of the series,
he realized that the thing,
the things that meant the most to him in this life for his wife and family,
so he was willing to give up his livelihood for which you never thought Ari
would ever do.
And that's where we pick up,
you know,
with him at the movie.
And,
um,
he is continuously trying to evolve.
And that's what I thought was brilliant about the movie was like doing a
spirituality tape,
having Ari gold,
attempting to be spiritual is,
is ridiculous and was really,
really fun to play.
And Doug,
just the look of horror as I was destroying a $250,000 Mercedes,
you know,
Jerry,
Jeremy has broken a lot of things on the set.
Um,
you know,
we kind of try to bring fake computers and stuff,
but they don't look good.
He's thrown him across the floor and you know what he really does?
He gets so into it and immerses himself,
you know,
really,
really deep and it's incredible to watch.
So.
Gotcha.
And how about your just,
uh,
for the writing process with the creating of the character's and kind of the
revolution?
Well,
I mean,
you know,
evolution,
it's a funny thing because the critics always want to talk evolution and actors
really want to talk evolution.
But for me,
you know,
this is a show about childhood best friends and really as you guys don't,
most of them don't change that much.
You know,
you usually go,
wow,
he's the same as he was.
Then there's a couple,
I mean,
Jer,
Jerry screwed me.
I mean,
Jerry went and got himself in shape.
Now he's this handsome guy,
you know,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean there's no doubt.
Yeah,
there's no doubt.
When I was casting turtle it was like,
okay,
I need a funny fat guy.
So,
um,
so then when we start getting into the movie,
Jerry and I are having lunch and Jerry is not eating anything again and I'm
like,
Jerry,
you got to eat some lunch.
He's like,
what do you mean?
I'm like,
well,
you're going to put on a hundred pounds,
right?
We're going to get you back.
And,
and the truth is he did have the most room for growth.
And um,
it's been an amazing thing to see.
I mean,
Jerry was so much younger than everybody else,
um,
when we started.
So,
but for everybody else,
their stories definitely have growth and any evolve.
But I think at the end of the day,
Ari was always this really good family man who just has a big mouth,
you know?
But he is a loyal guy and he'll kill for him.
And these guys too.
So their stories may change,
but at the end of the day they're core to me is,
is the same.
And I think the movie is almost a reset,
you know,
I like,
I hope you never had to see an episode to start this movie and go,
okay,
I get what this is.
And either you go along for the ride.
Okay.
You don't sell very much Kevin.
Well,
when I was coming up the stairs I tripped.
Is there any way that we could keep that off the internet?
It's never going to happen.
Right.
I should just accept that.
I'm going to be looking at that.
It's already on the Internet.
Literally tripped,
almost fell on my face and it was embarrassing.
We need more of that.
By the way.
I won't be pushing out all the stairs cause we need a viral moment that I saw a
couple cameras.
I'm hoping they were stills,
but I was literally on my face on the stairs coming up.
So if you'd be kind,
be cautious please.
Thank you.
Um,
no,
you know,
my character's Oh,
Ben trying to evolve for years,
but now he's having a baby.
So it's about as evolved as a,
as you can get.
So hopefully he'll grow up a little bit,
but we'll see.
Um,
so as you mentioned,
you know,
it's,
it's been a while since the pilot and it's been,
what,
11 years since you guys first stepped into these roles and,
and,
um,
you know,
you're bringing in a new audience to this film,
but you're also honoring the audience that loved and watched all of the show and
it was on,
um,
what were some of the things that you had to,
you know,
you took care with Tim to bring in the new audience?
We watched it with some people who hadn't seen any of the series before last
night,
and they loved it.
That's what you have succeeded.
But,
um,
I mean,
you know,
I,
I looked at the script when I started and said,
yeah,
there's things that we have to clean up from the moon,
from the show for fans,
but really just get into this as quickly as possible.
You know,
I didn't want to spend a lot of time on Vince got married and what happened and
Ari retired.
Okay.
He's a type a guy,
these types of guys all the time.
They say,
you know what,
going to pack it all up and then they end up coming right back,
you know it.
Um,
so it was very,
very important that Piers Morgan thing was obviously a device to catch people
up.
I needed something.
Piers was great and made a very credible in real.
But um,
you know,
it's,
at the end of the day,
this shows about working class guys who made it big and get to live in this
fantasy land.
At the end of the day,
they really care about each other more than they care about all the toys and
stuff.
So I think that's an easy thing to latch onto.
And if you like the characters,
you go along with it.
So yeah.
Was it easy to slip back into these characters?
You know,
it's been a reasonable amount of time since the series ended.
Did you guys find that you're just as comfortable with today as you were?
I mean,
I couldn't get,
I couldn't wait.
I mean,
I live in New York,
so I miss these guys.
And uh,
you know,
I was really just anxious for us all to get back together and being in our
characters because really,
you know,
acting is reacting.
And when you're working off,
you know,
Jeremy and,
and,
and all these other characters and you see Johnny drama,
it's,
it's really easy just to respond to that and be present.
The,
you know,
you touched on this a little bit where there's something really special about
these characters that we,
you know,
they all grew up from,
nothing came from nothing and the other extremely relatable and I loved it.
You know,
the juxtaposition with Haley,
Joel Osment character in the movie where he's like the air of the fire,
we'll have of the spot,
this family,
and he says it's entitled Brats.
So,
you know,
it was a secret of keeping these characters a wadeable even though,
the craziest stuff from our,
he and you know,
he making the mistakes.
But I think the things that makes you love these guys aside from obviously these
actors are likable.
It's an intangible that you,
you have to cast.
But you know,
Ari goes home to his wife and kids every night.
My son plays a son.
So I liked that he does that.
But,
um,
so you know,
and these guys,
and they say it and they do it with action,
it's more important that they look out for each other,
then they get a Ferrari.
So yeah,
all the toys are there because it is a wish fulfillment.
We want people to watch this and go,
wow,
that's a great life and I'd love to live it.
But more importantly,
I'd love to live it with my friends that really can't afford to do that.
You know?
And it's how I grew up and it's really how all of us kind of grew up.
And I'm still best friends with the kids that I was friends with from
kindergarten on.
So,
and a lot of them,
you know,
some of them,
I have friends who've made fortunes and I have friends who,
you know,
work as policemen and do all sorts of things.
And when we get together,
there's no difference.
It's the same dynamics that we had and that's what I really want with these
guys.
So,
so this question is for Jeremy and Doug.
Um,
you know,
Ari gold is a historic cinematic figure now,
um,
you know,
is there,
how much of it is,
is written in advance?
How much of it is Jeremy like improving?
One of my favorite scenes would been involved with paint,
a picture frame and a very innocent looking kitten.
My cat.
I'm sorry.
Um,
yeah.
How much room is there to play on set and how much,
how much of it is like a written in advance to be true to the character?
Well,
I mean it's all of our jobs to make the written word seem improvisational.
That's what,
that's what we do.
That's what we love
to do.
And so Doug,
you know,
it takes a long time to write this and he,
we honor those words and uh,
if something comes up,
you know,
I come from an Improv background and so I,
I do love to mix it up,
but this is really about making those words come to life.
So the stuff with the kitten,
all that is absolutely written.
You know,
I just,
I'm not an insane person that just decides to smash a glass kitten in the middle
of a scene.
You know what I mean?
Actually I probably would do that.
Yeah.
But no,
we had eight or 10 breakaway glasses,
glass cases,
and I just went to town and it was just cathartic.
But usually,
and with all of them,
I mean,
you know,
we'll do a take that's exactly like the script and then I'll go,
you got any ideas?
But more importantly they'll usually call me up the night before I got an a
line,
I got an idea.
And then Jeremy,
the biggest thing Jeremy always does,
which has given us some amazing moments is end of takes.
He'll just throw things in because like that scene in the psychiatrist office,
you know,
he's got a,
uh,
two,
two and a half page monologue for him to start improvising in the middle of that
would be a,
it would be mind boggling if he could do that,
you know.
So I think it's really those ends of moments where he comes up with,
we will try it.
But,
uh,
you know,
we try to,
we try to get the script,
especially cause you know,
we shot this in 34 days,
which I don't know if you guys know what that is.
A really short,
really short things.
So,
and we have a lot of dialogue.
The script was 160 pages.
A typical comedy is usually 105 maybe.
So we got to move and move and move.
So I gotcha.
And so,
uh,
Adrian and Kevin and I want to talk about your guys' relationship cause it's
almost very brotherly.
I mean I know you have your,
obviously your characters,
you know,
brothers would drama on the film,
but you guys are almost like brothers too,
it seems like.
So can you talk a little bit about that relationship and how that's kind of
played out?
Well,
I think,
uh,
I mean I was mad at managing is tomorrow's before,
before it moved me out to California.
But obviously,
you know,
uh,
it was probably a dynamic that,
you know,
started in,
in our childhood where he served,
trusted my judgment and sort of knew that I have it turns out maybe don't have
such great taste and material.
I definitely steer them down the wrong road a few times,
uh,
meeting and Queens Boulevard and name to name a few.
But,
uh,
I think more than anything,
there's just a trust there.
And,
uh,
you know,
I think that Vince knows that at the end of the day he has his best,
his best interest in mind.
Yeah.
And something happened.
It happened in the movie where suddenly he,
uh,
is,
is more of the sex symbol then Vince,
and we've been joking about whether or not Doug was mad at me or Kevin.
We literally,
I was like,
Doug,
what do I do?
It's like,
well,
and I,
and then I called the whole movie.
I was like,
Doug,
starving old scare people off.
You're not naked the whole ovary.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean the,
the they,
we are the straight men.
They know we're uh,
you know,
sort of part of what drives the story
forward because our solid grounding is sort of what gets these boys going and
keeps the bucks coming in.
Yep.
Um,
so one of my other favorite story lines,
and this was with Ronda Rousey cause she's a bad ass.
So was that role written explicitly with her in mind?
You know,
you've had some great people come in and play versions of themselves,
but she is,
I think a unique appearance of the entourage of universe.
And what was it like fighting her or trying to almost fight her?
Well,
you want to start with how she,
her,
I'll start.
Initially everyone saw the movie,
but I'm right.
Or I don't know.
But so initially she was the Armie Hammer role,
but rob there really,
I mean a year and a half ago,
almost two years when we cast her,
she was a very different place than she is today.
So she was kind of a little unknown.
I mean to the,
to the real fighting crowd.
They knew her,
but really not.
So,
um,
initially she was going to be the one that was like threatening Vince.
Like I thought it was a funny idea to have Vince.
And then Jerry and I were at lunch and I think honestly it was like at the same
moment,
but that we thought this would be a perfect thing for him.
Like there's something that just seemed like a perfect combination and I had
never even met her,
but we,
we,
we set it and then we set a lunch with her.
We had a lunch with her and weirdly enough,
she had just started randomly watching the show at a training session.
So she was up to,
I don't know if Jerry like season five.
Yeah.
Something like that.
So,
and then,
uh,
we went to lunch and they immediately had a really cool chemistry and,
and um,
so Jerry can take it from there with,
yeah,
I was just,
I was a big fan of her is way before she came on to do the entourage movie.
And,
uh,
it was weird,
but she went to,
because we did all this stuff,
and again,
I don't want to give too much away for those who haven't seen it,
but we did all the nonphysical stuff first.
I'm getting to know her as,
as just Rhonda,
the person and she's just really sweet,
charming,
intelligent woman.
And I just,
I wasn't getting it.
I was like,
how is she this?
I can't imagine how she could be as intimidating as people think.
And then we did the stuff in the cage and I saw her face change from like,
oh,
this is Rhonda.
The persons who Rhonda,
I'm a whoop your ass.
Jerry's fees changed real quick too.
Honestly.
I,
you know,
uh,
in terms of acting,
it didn't really take a whole lot to react to her charging across the ring and
giving me a front kick to the stomach.
And she actually recommended,
there's a little bit of a flip in the movie where she flips me in and I wanted
to do it.
I wanted to try to be a part of all the stones and all that.
And she said,
Jerry,
listen,
you're not the biggest guy in the world.
I've broken guys ribs before who are a lot bigger than you.
I just looked over at the stunt man,
I think,
and in my mind he was having like a coffee and I think I grabbed his coffee and
I tagged him in and he got his words is probably appropriate,
but she's also won three fights,
I think since the time we started shooting the movie.
And she's an incredible person
and you can also,
as a man,
you want to believe that you can.
You can beat her up.
I mean it's fine.
You Kevin,
Kevin Dillon was sitting there was like,
Bro,
I could take her,
you know,
no.
Walberg walked in and I forget where said something like,
uh,
you look like a Clint Eastwood in,
what,
what's that?
That movie?
Uh,
where he was like,
meet everybody.
But anyway,
Dylan,
I think Dylan,
until he saw Jerry there,
he was being serious.
I think he was like,
because he'd never seen her fight.
And then just the one you see the movement that this really is an interesting
one on the cover of sports illustrated,
the most dominant athlete in the world.
It's amazing to watch and the transformation,
like he says in our personalities.
Incredible.
And something weird happened.
Now anytime I watch a fight of her,
as I turned it to Adrian from the rocky movies,
I'm like in the crowd,
like at home,
like crying at the TV,
just praying.
It's u Windsor.
If I turned it to Adrian from the rocky movies when I watch her thighs.
So your money's on her over Mayweather,
right.
If she actually fights an absolute.
Okay,
good.
Um,
so you know,
I think anybody in everybody in Hollywood wants to be in an entourage episode,
movie,
everything.
Um,
at what point do you have to start saying no to people?
Like it's,
it's takes place in Hollywood.
So it's awesome that you are able to integrate so many awesome cameos.
Just like everyone who wants to buy tickets.
We will say no to no one,
anyone.
I mean,
we got calls,
we're on the set and I get a call that the clay Matthews from the Green Bay
packers is in town and,
and he's got a wedding,
but it's his favorite show.
He's willing,
he's willing to miss the wedding if we can find something for him.
I'm like,
all right,
come on down.
You know,
so we,
you know,
it's like a fire sale.
Come on down.
We packed it in.
And the truth is some people go,
what's with all the cameos?
That's the life that Mark Walberg leaves.
You know,
when the movie was finished,
I called them up and said,
I'm going to bring it to your house to show it to you.
I get there and Kevin Duran answers the door.
I'm like,
I'm not ready to show it the Kevin Duran yet.
And he's like,
well,
you're going to,
so let's go.
So it's just,
that's what it is.
So the,
the more we can get in a realistic version that the better.
So
that's great.
And uh,
you know,
Jeremy Fellows,
Chicago native go cubbies.
Let's,
yeah,
right.
Why not?
What the cubs on that one,
Huh?
Back row,
we'll be quiet now.
Well,
you really want to,
you know,
you were really one of the big oak characters,
early on in the show.
So,
you know,
Ari,
he just seems destined to always kind of go for that top job.
He has his own agency and then he,
you know,
bronze now a studio head.
So kind of what is that top goal for Ari?
Because he just keeps chasing and chasing and Jayson gets names.
Yeah.
He,
he's ridiculously ambitious and,
and he will,
nothing could stop him.
Uh,
he believes he's qualified for every job.
And I th I think that,
mmm.
He's actually a great studio head.
I can't tell you what happens.
Okay.
Um,
but
ultimately I could see him going into politics and going ridiculously far.
I don't think there's anything that he wouldn't be able to accomplish or think
that he could heal.
He would will it to happen no matter what.
MMM.
Okay.
And you know,
Doug,
what was,
you know,
kind of the challenges of getting this would be made and was there any fear of
it's too late or we've ended it or
I'm a neurotic Jew,
so I'm always in fear,
but,
um,
the,
you know,
the challenge was the script get a script,
right?
They could sustain itself for 90 minutes and really,
you know,
feel like a movie.
Um,
you know,
in the show I could have lean on one character and less on someone and then the
next week switch it around this.
Everyone had to have a full thing.
And like I said,
the script was extremely long.
Uh,
you know,
I told Warner brothers the studio because they were very worried about it.
I said,
I believe me,
we speak fast and these guys are going to go,
go,
go.
So,
you know,
the movie is obviously not long even though the script was,
but the script was the biggest challenge.
And then,
you know,
these guys schedules,
they all,
you know,
had different things they were doing and finding the time to get it in together.
But once we got into production,
it was,
it was pretty smooth sailing.
I'm going to start taking audience questions if you guys want to start lining up
at the mic.
Yeah.
Um,
and so speaking of this script of Oh wow,
he was right.
Three hours.
Wow.
Um,
before,
before we get to the last question from us.
Um,
so,
uh,
speaking of this script,
you know,
you,
you decided to bring in alcohol and them villains,
uh,
you know,
the outside forces of pseudo evil,
that challenge these guys that are,
you know,
Billy Bob Thornton and Haley Joel Osment as though the Larson [inaudible] Larson
and dad tribes some creepy.
Um,
what was the decision to bring in an outside kind of negative force as opposed
to going with one of the,
uh,
you know,
various challenges that the guys have met up against in previous?
You know,
what I really wanted to shed a light on,
on kind of what's happening in Hollywood now,
you know,
um,
the studio is really our farming,
these movies out in the hedge fund guys and people who don't care about movies
at all.
And,
and you know,
it's been a joke for Hollywood for 20 years,
that the studios don't care about the movies.
Now you've got another layer where it is just,
what is it worth?
What does each person a value?
So a,
we just thought that was an interesting way to do it.
And you know,
it's a very realistic look at those guys.
I mean,
because you know,
there are those guys that come in and I've had those words said to me like,
I don't give a crap whether this movie's good.
I only care if it makes money.
So,
and,
you know,
when you put your heart and soul into it,
you know it,
that's hurtful.
And obviously you get it.
We all want to make money.
That's,
you know,
uh,
the business of it.
But you want to make a good movie.
That's what you set out to do.
So,
okay,
great.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
Two questions.
First one.
Where's Lloyd?
And the second question is,
can you talk about your favorite cameo each you who your favorite person to work
with was?
Where's Lloyd today?
Yeah.
Right now we saw,
we saw him last night.
It's a premiere.
We should have brought them.
Actually we had to see,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
He actually is Raleigh filming today cause he's doing it.
He's doing a new TV show and now my favorite cameo in the movie because it's so
bizarre that he's in the same movie as Gary Busey is Warren Buffet.
It was just weird,
you know,
so,
and,
and Warren came to the set cause he wanted to make a,
uh,
he wanted to make a little film with the entourage guys,
for the Berkshire Hathaway stock holders meeting.
So I said,
okay,
but you're going to be in the movie now.
So,
um,
and he was great.
It was a great sport.
So,
well actually I want to follow up with that.
Uh,
there was a short film that was released online with Ras character kind of
transitioning him from the series into the movie.
And it,
was that ever part of the movie?
Was it kind of like,
do we want to include this or was it just pulled complete,
separate thing,
you know?
Um,
but it was great cause Cadillac gave us an opportunity to show that kind of
bridge.
So,
um,
and you know,
when that car doesn't exist.
So it was nice day.
I saw that four years ago and it gave me an inspiration for the movie.
But uh,
they're not even going to,
they're not even planning on making it.
So
big fan of the show questions for Doug,
Jeremy Agent.
What was more painful to watch?
He break his leg on set filming the football scene or turtle get beat up by
Ronda Rousey.
Thanks.
But by far,
seeing Kevin
get hurt.
I mean,
but I mean,
cause Jerry Real,
by the way,
that's a very,
it's a metal rod metal plate and eight screws in my leg.
So I like to take it,
by the way,
this is a very rob Rod Koski question because Kevin,
it was Jerry tackled him and Kevin said,
well I thought I heard something pop.
And then 20 minutes later they tell me that Russell Wilson,
Rob Gronkowski,
you're holding ice on his leg.
I think they're,
I think they're punking me.
And we'd go upstairs and Gronk calcium wants to shoot him up with a Tarald shot
to get them back on the field.
And he says,
what else do you have to do today?
And Kali says,
well,
I,
I'm a sexy.
And Greg Koski is like,
well,
you can't get shut off if you have sex.
And he's like,
I'm not having sex.
I'm rob.
Hey,
back then to break this to you buddy.
But we don't actually have sex.
So I don't know
actually have to,
you know,
finish it the deal,
if you know what I mean.
I just have to pretend,
you know.
But,
uh,
yeah,
no,
I mean,
I knew my leg was broken.
I think a few few people did.
Doug was I just thinking denial because they know,
you know,
Doug's one of my buddies,
and I know he would never want me working hurt,
but you know,
I kind of walked her hobbled around for a few days then on the broken leg.
And we actually,
when I did,
uh,
some people just done,
I was exaggerating.
So we did this sex scene.
Yeah.
Jerry.
I'm like,
Jerry,
did you hear that?
Sounded like chop a chopstick.
Go.
That's it.
It's sent literally.
And uh,
so this girl is as on top of me and I'm like,
I'm,
you have to be careful of my leg.
And she said,
rolling
rise.
I'm like,
no,
my leg is broken.
Just saying okay.
Yeah,
no John,
you're like,
so uh,
yeah,
no it hurt.
I mean I got through it.
Thank God we were had sunglasses on and it was a party scene.
So that was basically,
and he was on Molly so he could act as weird as you want it.
Like Doug was like,
you really look like you're on drugs.
I'm like,
oh I was,
I was on plenty of drugs.
He's like,
all right,
well don't tell anybody cause it looks like you can act actually for once in
your life.
I did not say that.
Yeah.
I just like to say from the back row,
I have never seen,
seen such a heroic display as Kevin plane through the whole week on a broken
leg.
I would've,
I would've
random falling and crying,
come on me.
He deserves that.
And the truth is almost any other day,
you know,
you can shut down for six weeks that day when you have Greg Koski there,
Russell Wilson,
Clay Matthews,
Bob said,
there's no way we're getting them all about Mike Tyson that you're going to get
them all back together.
So the fact that Kevin,
and again,
no one told him to keep,
in fact,
I actually kept saying,
you need to go to the hospital.
And he was like,
no,
I'm fine.
But um,
so,
but it did save us.
It really did it,
but no one knew.
Right.
It's funny too because Rhonda,
you know,
you're around these people that's ground Koski Ronda Rousey one,
one person tougher than the other and I don't know.
I'm not tough.
So I'm like,
yeah,
I think my legs broken and,
and Rhonda was like,
your leg is not broken.
I was like,
I'm like,
I'm pretty sure it's broken.
You're saying,
Kevin,
if your leg was broken,
you wouldn't be standing here and we wouldn't be having this conversation.
And I went,
okay,
I guess so roll the cameras.
Total sense.
That makes total sense.
So yeah,
keep drinking.
Hey,
so my question is,
uh,
towards the end of the series,
how much influence did mark Walberg still have on it?
And,
uh,
in the movie as well?
Okay.
I mean,
mark,
you know,
his influence didn't change and mark from the beginning kind of let me have the
reins that you can do what you want with my life and do,
you know,
mix and match it with other people.
So Mark's best thing was being a producer,
which is,
you know,
I needed Martin Scorsese and mark would call him up and get them,
mark really got this movie made,
you know,
he,
I ran into him,
I kind of thought the show was over and I ran into him and he's like,
where's the script?
Everyone's asking me every press junket I do for the odds are I was crip.
I like,
oh,
I don't know,
is anyone really gonna want to make that?
And he said,
I promise you write the script and I'll get it made.
Some work has been,
uh,
you know,
the real definition of a producer,
but he's never gone.
Like,
Oh,
here's a story,
let's put this in there,
or whatever.
So,
okay.
Yeah,
I think mark believed in us from the beginning.
That was one of the best things he ever dig,
at least from me speaking from me.
I mean I felt very confident at a young age knowing that a guy like Walberg
believed so much in this and was putting his name on it and he was behind.
It just felt good confidence wise.
And then he also gave us the confidence that there was a market for the movie.
Like we,
we,
we didn't know.
We were all say,
well,
you know,
but he was like,
guys,
I know this is going to work.
Just like he's always done.
He's been a great sort of,
you know,
I just influence across the board for the entire run.
Yeah.
And it,
and it's interesting from the beginning,
you know,
the,
the scariest screening I've ever had.
If this was the pilot at his house with his crew,
which is like 30 deep and,
uh,
you know,
obviously Adrian is a very different type of,
of actor than,
than Marcus.
And,
uh,
you know,
it comes on and there's 30,
I don't want to call them thugs with tough guys from Boston.
An agent comes on and when it goes,
Maki would kick the crap out of that guy,
you know,
and uh,
and the thing ended and everyone was like,
you know,
Kinda quiet.
And mark got up and he was like,
I,
and I'm thinking the whole time,
like,
they hate this.
This is a nightmare.
This is the worst thing that ever happened.
Did up and mark it up because we got a huge hit here.
I guarantee it.
And,
uh,
he's been that kind of supportive and,
and since day one,
so,
hey guys,
I'm a huge fan of the show.
Saw the movie last night.
Fantastic.
Um,
my question is actually for Jeremy Piven,
uh,
Ari gold.
Um,
so what first,
well,
two questions actually.
First off,
what
is your favorite Ari gold insole that you've ever done?
A show or movie?
And then the second question is,
can we hug it out?
They want to come up here and hug him for real?
He's approaching,
he's a pro.
[inaudible]
uh,
the gift that keeps giving.
How much do you hate dug for that?
Do you love it?
I'm like,
oh no,
no,
it's all good.
I,
I mean,
yeah,
that was one of those moments where I was,
when Kevin and I were very early on at the end of a scene and they didn't yell
cut.
So we just kind of kept going.
And then here we are 11 years later and people are asking to hug me.
So it's
task,
at least that they say to me,
let's hug it out,
get a little bitch,
get over here and hug it out.
You little bitch.
And literally once a day somebody yells at me,
I like the APP outside of their car window.
I go,
are you doing to meet June 3rd?
Um,
as far as,
um,
I almost want to ask you guys what,
what your favorite Artie golden sold was.
I don't think we can say,
hey,
I am five.
And again,
all of you saw Jeremy as Ari gold on CNBC last week saying it's anal anal night
at the gold's house be which was aligned from season one or maybe the pilot
even,
I don't know.
Yeah,
so,
but uh,
well they asked Doug Rohde a foe,
uh,
Ari gold autobiography called rules to rule by,
and I went out to promote it and I,
I,
I was obligated,
literally contractually obligated.
I swear to God to show up as Ari gold and,
and I,
I had my publicist tell all these people like,
we're on live television.
You guys know that this,
if I show up as this character were on the today show,
I know you're live,
but how am I going to play Ari gold without swearing?
I mean,
it's,
it's would be like a UFC fighter without striking,
you know,
you have to,
you have to get,
and sure enough,
like every show I went on,
I just started swearing
and people were furious.
I had to apologize to the today show.
I just kept screaming.
Can I swear here by the way?
Yeah.
I mean,
I kept like,
at one point it was like a hockey fight fight where you pulled the Jersey over
to the other guy's head.
You just keep swinging.
Like I just kept screaming rapid the fuck up on live television.
And then I snapped out of it and realize my God,
what is,
what has been happening?
It's a big,
what's the balance of that?
Because some of the stuff he says is just,
it's,
it's so funny,
but it's so crazy.
Is that why it works?
Because it's just completely crazy stuff.
I've never ever censored it.
And the truth is,
it is a special actor who can say,
cause I mean,
again,
most of the lines are written and I've tried to say that myself and if I said
him,
they would be,
I mean,
it'd be horrifying,
but Jeremy has an intangible,
like I said,
to be a lovable asshole.
And you know,
at the end of the day that he loves Lloyd and that to,
he has his back the same way these guys do.
So to,
to Rex's credit racks is tough as nails,
man.
You're,
you're not going to hurt his feelings at all.
So I mean,
like Jeremy will say that he will run it by racks in the morning and ask him if
it's okay if I talk about things getting squirted on your face or whatnot.
And,
and rex really doesn't care.
He's never,
he's like,
he's just like tough is now.
Yeah,
he,
he was always up for it.
He found it funny.
He just,
nothing fazed him whatsoever.
So it made it,
it made it a little bit easier.
But there will be times where I would read the script and just think they're
there.
There's no coming back from this.
I will,
I will turn off everyone that has ever watched the show.
And so that was our challenge when it was really fun.
This questions,
this question's for uh,
Jeremy as well.
Um,
you mentioned that you came from a Improv background,
so I was wondering what were the inspirations,
if any,
at all for the Ra gold character?
Well,
um,
as Doug was saying earlier,
I mean,
Mark Walberg is,
is the one is the reason why we're all here and it's loosely based on his world.
And Ari Emanuel is his agent,
you know,
it's no secret.
Um,
and Ari Emanuel is a incredibly powerful agent.
Started Way Morris and then bought a,
I mean it started endeavour bought.
William Morris just took over IMG,
he's taken over the world and you know,
he is a fast talking shark,
um,
who is incredibly abrasive and you know,
you know,
is brilliant and prolific in what he does and has add and all these wonderfully
beautiful qualities that you see in the fictional character.
And I have heard that in the middle of business calls,
he'll just go,
you don't want to be the guy from TV.
You want to be the guy from the show.
I beat the guy from the show going to be the guy from the show.
And,
and I remember I was with him in Vegas one time.
We were sitting there and he said to the waitress,
I'm the real Ari,
you don't have the real [inaudible].
And I'm like,
she doesn't even know who the real aria is.
Stop saying that she doesn't have cable.
So he looks like you're insane.
Stop saying.
And so,
um,
so,
uh,
we're gonna wrap it up here with a question.
Uh,
last question.
So,
uh,
what are your guys favorite kind of character moments from either the series of
the movie?
Just kind of what you're most proud of about,
about the entire thing?
Well,
I mean,
you know,
for me,
uh,
we were able to do things as a,
as a,
as a production crew,
um,
that,
that TV shows at that time weren't doing,
I mean,
when we did the Sundance episode,
you know,
we were there shooting and Sundance and nobody really knew,
any of us were,
I mean,
Jeremy has been around Jeremy's,
you've been in a bunch of money,
so people knew Jeremy was,
but for the,
for the four guys were just kind of walking around and we looked like a little
indie.
So we're stealing shots at Sundance and then,
and then we did the same thing at the Cannes film festival and the U Two
concert.
And the Laker Games.
So for me the,
the best part of the experience has,
and I'm sure you guys will agree to a certain extent,
it's been sort of the live sort of shooting and some of the things that as a
production,
the whole team effort we were able to pull off.
Yeah.
Uh,
for me,
we kind of this and credit to Doug on this too,
like the style of the walk and talk,
which is something that we've done on this show since the beginning where it's a
three or four page scene and it's either a four or five of us in the actual
scene and it's,
it's one camera,
one shot,
no cuts,
and it has a feeling like a play almost.
Cause you can get three quarters of the way through the scene,
one little screw up and you're going back to one to start again.
So that always gave a new kind of energy to a scene.
And you also know if you knock it out and everyone's on top of their game,
you get to go home early,
which is always kind of fun.
But,
uh,
no,
see it like that,
that added so much to the show for I,
I had never experienced anything like that.
And like just having no close ups or nothing like sharing the frame with four
guys and it's still,
the scene is just as equally funny,
if not even more funny.
It was always pretty cool to do.
Um,
you know,
there's a misperception that this show is only a sh show and now a guy's movie.
But that's in fact not true.
It's,
you know,
it's not just a bunch of uncouth crude guys.
There's a lot of heart to this show and I think it's,
I think a lot of women really respond to it.
And there's a,
there's a,
yeah,
that's a fan on the audience.
I know.
And by the way,
women can be quite crude as well,
but,
but uh,
there's,
there are moments in this movie and one in particular where I literally tear up.
It's so touching and beautiful the way these guys treat each other and how they
have each other's back.
And I really love that about this show.
It's got so much,
so much dynamic and so much depth and also just a lot of superficial fun.
Jeremy [inaudible].
Um,
God,
I don't even know where to start because it's,
you know,
there's you,
you throw yourself into every scene and every episode,
every season.
So,
um,
yeah,
I think it would actually be ultimately I think the movie is
okay
better than anything.
It's like the culmination of everything we've ever done.
And I don't know if Doug was new when he was writing,
for instance,
that last episode that he was planting the seeds to give for instance already
this conundrum,
you know,
to be the king of Hollywood or to forget it all and prove himself to his wife
that he,
she means the world to him.
But he basically planted seeds perfectly for the movie.
And I think the movie is really about something and it is a male fantasy,
see a male fantasy show,
but you won't see that coming that it really is about loyalty and friendship and
then ultimately family and all these great things.
So to do that,
to pull it off and to make it funny and entertaining and then to sit with
audiences and watch them laugh and really get it and be with it.
That's really gratifying.
Okay.
What about your,
Doug,
cause you've just seen the entire series.
Yeah,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
not to be corny.
This stuff with my son.
Uh,
Jeremy,
I think Jeremy said that my son when he was five,
she would play his son and he's not an actor.
I'm not trying to turn them into,
you know,
one of these crazy kids.
But,
uh,
so the only thing he's done is this,
but the,
those moments on the set and basically that he's grown up with these guys.
Um,
it's not quite boyhood,
but you know,
it's,
uh,
it's been great to my quiet and even,
and honestly to watch him in the movie.
I don't know if you saw him last night,
but I mean he got to,
you know,
the screen is,
I've been through,
he got a huge laugh and it just,
it,
it makes me very happy.
So.
Great.
All right,
thank [inaudible].
Thank you guys for being here.
Hey guys,
guys,
actually guys,
feel welcome.
Yes.
Movies out June 3rd
get off the end.
Please keep that shout off the Internet.
I thank you guys.